[Music]
hey you guys
tomes of terror book review time once
again
today we are doing a sequel to a book
that i did
a long time ago i think it was back in
november like mid-november of 2020
and that book was called the nightmare
room so if you want to go back and watch
my review of that
this is actually the second book in the
series uh to trilogy called the messy
man series
and this is the second one this is
called the hungry ones
by chris sorensen the nightmare room
came out in 2018 as i mentioned on that
one and it was kind of like
one of the you know it was picked like
by a bunch of different horror channels
and stuff like that is like they're one
of their favorite books of the year
and it actually was a really awesome
like haunted house novel
it's interesting because not too long
after i did the review
of uh the nightmare room the author
chris sorensen contacted me and asked if
i would
like the other two books in the series
which is this one the hungry ones number
two
and number three which is called the
messy man and uh so he very generously
sent them to me after he saw my review
and he signed them and everything and
it's super cute
and look he wrote in there you drew a
little ghost which i thought was pretty
awesome like look at that that's really
awesome
okay so this came out like in 2019 i
think i i am gonna say this is gonna be
hard to talk about because
one thing i will say i'm not sure i mean
it's hard for me to say because
i actually did read the first book in
the series before i read this one
so i'm not sure how well this book plays
as a standalone i'm sure you could
probably still read it as a standalone
but i feel like if you didn't read the
first one
there might be parts of it that are sort
of unclear
or you know maybe you don't really get
what the mythology is and stuff like
that so
as i said it's kind of hard for me to
judge because i actually did read the
first book although it was longer ago
than
i probably should have which i'll get
into in a minute i don't know so i'd be
interested to see if somebody that had
just read this one or like read this one
first
if they had any idea what was going on
because it seemed to me that
you would really have to have read the
first book to
at least get full appreciation for what
was going on in this one
even though the story of this one is
pretty much
i don't say it's like completely
different because like the method the
mythology is the same
but it expands the mythology and it goes
like in a lot of different
uh directions and directions i wasn't
really uh expecting that said though i
actually ended up really liking this
book
i don't think it was as scary or as
creepy as the first one
but it was for sure just as entertaining
uh the characters i think are kind of
the highlight like i really really like
um the way that chris hornson writes
characters
and that was um definitely in evidence
in this one as well
and plus i liked that because you know
as i mentioned in my review of the
nightmare room which was essentially
a haunted house story although
the entity wasn't really a ghost so that
was like kind of original
this one kind of takes that entity
concept
and like expands on it so it's going to
be really really hard to talk about this
one without spoiling stuff from the
first book
so if that's going to be a problem for
you then i would recommend like
not watching this because i'm not gonna
you know i don't want to spoil every
single thing in the story but
it's really really difficult to talk
about this one without spoiling some
pretty major [ __ ] that happened in the
first one
so you've been warned i'm just saying it
there might be some spoilers i'm not
meaning to like ruin anyone's reading
experience or anything like that
but it is kind of hard to talk about if
you can't talk about what happened in
the first one
so as i mentioned the first book the
nightmare room essentially just um
more or less straightforward haunted
house story about uh family the larsens
peter and hannah and they've lost a son
michael the cancer
and they end up moving back to peter's
hometown of
maple city which i think is in illinois
and
them ending up living in this old
farmhouse that was owned by peter's dad
and there being an entity in there that
keeps coming out at first like reveals
itself
on peter's uh you know audiobook because
he's an audiobook narrator
just as the author chris sorensen is and
it kind of slowly evolves from there and
then it kind of goes back and forth
in time between the modern day and
between
a kid that used to live in the farmhouse
and the two stories linked together
so in the first one there's just
essentially
two kind of interconnected narratives
now this one he does something very
interesting
so pretty much i mean from like the
first few pages of this book
um you get pretty much sucked in like
almost immediately because
pretty much the first scene is there's
this old motel
in maple city it's just this rundown
kind of roadside motel type joint
and this dude named butch comes upon
this place it's called the crossroads
and he basically has a shotgun and he
blows away the 12 people that are
staying at the hotel
and you're led to believe that there is
something kind of
making him do it like controlling him in
some sort of fashion
so after that opening like i said aware
of 12 people just get blown away in cold
blood
so that's you know starts with a bang if
you want to say that
then it goes to this woman named jessie
voss
now jessie voss has decided and she's
not really enter
entirely sure why and it doesn't really
become all that clear until later on in
the book
but she's decided that she wants to
buy the crossroads motel which i think
it's like two years later
like she comes along and she sees this
place and obviously it's abandoned and
like gone to [ __ ] now because this
horrible tragedy happened there and
nobody wants anything to do with it
but for some reason she feels compelled
to buy this place
and fix it up and reopen it
so she does that so like the first part
of the book is her
and her friend and they're um you know
going through the process
of fixing the place up they've renamed
it they're calling it the intermission
motor lodge and she's like really
jazzed about it and it's like i don't
know why i just really got into
like jessie is a really cool character
and her friend steph who is helping her
out
uh is also a really good character so
like i said chris sorensen again
very very good at writing just likeable
compelling
characters that you really like come to
care about like in a very short period
of time and you really
want to see what they're going to do you
don't want bad things to happen to them
and whatnot
now at this point you know there's maybe
kind of
little hints here and there that maybe
there's something to do
with you know this place being haunted
uh which you know if any place beyond it
it would be some place where
a gunman came in and blew away 12 random
people including some children
in an old motel so there's kind of like
hints of that kind of stuff happening
but you don't really get tied in with
the first book
until a car pulls up in front of the
motel
uh and these are the first guests of the
motel now at this point like i said
this is gonna spoil some [ __ ] that
happened in the first book
a little bit i guess so i'm just saying
like you know
i'm warning you again so as i mentioned
in the first book the nightmare room
peter and hannah larson their son
michael
has died of cancer and he died like at
some point prior to the events of the
book
now when the car pulls up in front of
the new intermission motor lodge
the motel that jesse has bought and
fixed up
it's peter and hannah larson in the car
and their son michael is with them and
is
alive now michael had cancer
at some point but he is in remission
like he's recovered from it
so from that point forward you know that
this is
sort of like an alternate timeline
now in the first novel he did kind of
hint around
at because of the way that the um the
pastor and the present story were linked
and then the way that that story ended
like with peter
you know doing what he did so it kind of
like placed the seeds
of that type of idea where i don't want
to call it like
time travel it's not it's not exactly
time travel but i guess it kind of is
time travel maybe but yeah so it's it's
just kind of like playing with the idea
of being able to be outside of time and
being able to go back
and change things so when the
larson family pulls up and michael is
still alive and has survived his
bout with cancer you know that these
this is the same family from the first
book but they're a different version
like an alternate timeline version of
them
because like when they show up at the
motel this is actually
they're coming back to maple city
because
of peter's dad being in uh you know
big bear being in the um in the home and
like not doing so well and
them moving back to the city just like
they were at the beginning of the first
book
but this is like an alternate timeline
where their son did not die
so that's how that ties in with the
first book
now we have still the entity
known as mr tal or whisper
but at this point him and the version of
peter that was in the first book
are have become sort of integrated uh so
it's almost kind of like i almost was
provided a little bit of like a venom
type situation where it's just kind of
like
he's not a person anymore but it's an
entity and it's almost kind of like
whisper wants to do one thing and but
peter still has enough of his
personality from the other timeline to
to know like to keep whisper from doing
like bad [ __ ]
however uh there are also three other
entities
uh just known as i think basically she's
just known as sister and then she has a
couple of
other uh acolytes i guess that are you
know just known as her brothers
and they're kind of like i don't know
i've seen like i saw some other um
reviewers like compare them to vampires
which i guess they sort of are
but they essentially feed on
ghosts is what they do i think they're
not like not allowed
like they go around like in bone form
but they have like a living person
that kind of carts them around and does
their bidding like does things
um for them because they can't do a lot
of things for themselves
and then the person gets things in
return or at least they promise
to give them things in return so at this
point so that kind of ties back to
the very beginning of the story where
the dude butch was like blowing away all
those people at the
motel um because what they do like i
said they
they get living people to kill people
to make more ghosts that they can feed
on because it's almost like they're
feeding on their memories they're
feeding on souls essentially hence the
name the hungry ones so
not only do you have the larson family
whose son michael is now alive in this
alternate timeline
and you have this woman jessie who's who
owns this motel
and her friend steph and then you have
this other dude that shows up
at the motel named wood and he was
he's kind of the guy that is now
being sort of like the acolyte for the
hungry ones like carrying them around
and like doing their bidding and stuff
like that so
so all of this kind of happens at this
one
motel like this big kind of like
supernatural paranormal
paranormal showdown type of thing that's
going on
so as i said this is a very very
different
book than the first one like the
mythology is the same you still have
you know these entities that sort of
feed on souls or feed on
memories or whatever you have that going
on
but it's a lot more expansive
there's a lot more stuff going on
i don't know if i'd call it like in the
spirit realm not exactly but you do have
some characters that like come out of
their bodies and then can do things
like you know in in the realm like where
the hungry ones are
you know so you have that kind of stuff
going on there's a lot of ghost type of
[ __ ]
like people see in ghosts there's a
return of the character
of ellen marks who i believe was in the
first one who was kind of like the
little woman with all with all the black
clothes that's kind of like a psychic
and she's real
what's the word i'm looking for who's
real uh caustic
and abrasive and honestly i really like
that character a lot
um she doesn't really show up until
probably like the last quarter of the
book
but uh yeah whenever she shows up she's
super funny because she just kind of
like
she's just so like brusque like the way
she talks to everybody and she's like
very no-nonsense and
she's kind of like i'm busy you leave me
alone like so i really really like that
character
so she doesn't show up till the last
quarter but like to kind of help figure
everything out
but yeah so as i said i think the
strengths of this
are the character work and the expansion
of the mythology from the first one in
directions i didn't really expect i did
not expect there to be alternate
timelines
i did not expect like this kind of i
just didn't expect it to go that way and
i thought that was really really cool as
i said
it's a lot the first book was fairly
simple like i said as being
essentially a straightforward ever
fairly straightforward haunted house
story with like just a couple
interlinking plot lines
this one is a lot more complicated in
regards to like there being a lot more
characters and they're also being a lot
more uh entities and there being a lot
of like shenanigans going on like
interdimensional type stuff
almost to a sense where it's kind of
like clive barkery in
i want to say like not that extreme
maybe but in that ballpark so i
liked that a lot as i said the first one
i think was creepier
like scary because you know i you know
me i love haunted house [ __ ]
so um so the first one was like creepier
scarier
this one was much more not so much scary
as kind of
almost more like action-oriented i don't
know if i want to say action-oriented
that sounds kind of
weird but that's not exactly what i mean
but this one is a lot more
concerned about like just the pacing
it's like there's some
there's some gory [ __ ] there's ghost
[ __ ] it's kind of like there's some kind
of
funny like over-the-top sort of imagery
like there's this whole
plot thing like plot thread surrounding
this big plexiglas
cow that used to sit on top of the motel
that kind of like communicates with
people it's like not really but
it's kind of like that so it's kind of
like so it's funnier
i mean like the first one had some funny
[ __ ] in it too but this one is
funnier in the sense that a lot of the
characters are kind of funny some of the
situations are kind of
strange and sort of funny also
so it's a little bit different in that
regard like less scary more
i don't know more propulsive i guess and
just kind of more
more characters more complex but that
said it's like i think i still like the
nightmare room slightly better
but it's kind of hard to say because
this one
even though you can tell it's the same
author um because he's very uh
you know he's an awesome writer really
and it's like he just has a really deft
hand with like characterization
particularly
and also in like uh his descriptions are
very vivid and things like that so it's
and he's very good at pacing also like
he's very good at getting you to like
sit down and like just
read through the [ __ ] like he's like oh
man what's gonna happen next oh man
what's gonna happen next
so it's like i mean i think i remember
like saying on the first
on the review of the nightmare room that
i just like sat down and read almost the
whole thing without even like realizing
it
and i did a similar thing with this one
too this one is more
i think this one was like a slightly
less than that because it was kind of
more
and it's not episodic but it's a little
choppier because there's like scenes are
like shorter
you know i mean but the pacing is like
really really good and the ending is
really really good um you know the
ending of the nightmare room was also
really good so he really does stick the
landings which a lot of horror authors
don't do
so uh so props to that like the endings
are very satisfying
one thing i will say is that i wish
because i remember when i reviewed the
nightmare room and i went back and
looked and it was november
16th i think 2020 of last year so i read
it in november of last year
and i said oh yeah i'm gonna have to
read the second one and then it was like
a month or two later and then he sent me
the second one and the third one
and i was like and i remember doing on
my um 2021 tbr
i remember saying oh you know i got the
two books that was in you know that was
back in january
and i'm gonna have to read these pretty
soon because i don't want to like forget
what happened in the nightmare room
and i will say that if you're going to
read these
i would recommend reading them close
together
because although i did remember
um most of the [ __ ] that happened in the
nightmare room
i kind of wish that i had read this
i mean because i started reading it and
i'm like oh wait was that that was and
then i had to go back and
like look at the first book to make sure
and as i said i'm not sure if the second
book
works as a standalone if you don't know
anything about
the first book i don't know if you'd be
confused but like i said it's hard for
me to say because i did read the first
book
but i was a little bit disoriented at
first
when i started reading it because it had
been so long since i'd read the last one
that i didn't immediately remember all
the details and i had to go back and
like refresh my memory and stuff
so i will recommend that if if you're
going to read these and i
and i really do recommend that you do
because they're really good
read them in order because i think if
you read the second one you're just
being like what the hell is going on
like what who are these people and what
you know it's i think you could still
read it as a standalone i guess but
you'll get a lot more out of it if you
read the first one first
because if you don't read the first one
first you don't understand that the
second one is like an alternate timeline
you know what i mean and i think that's
kind of like a big deal like for you to
realize that
so definitely read them in order if
you're going to i
just wish that i had read them closer
together and it just made me mad that it
took me so long to get around to reading
the second one
because i think that it would probably i
don't know at some point i think i'll
probably
i mean obviously i still have to read
the third one the messy man and i'm not
gonna wait as long in between
this time i promise but i think what
i'll do is
at some point i'll do a reread of all
three of them
like in one go and then maybe i can do
like another video
updating i don't know that's maybe like
farther down the line
but i definitely think that they all
need to be read like in pretty quick
succession
otherwise you don't get as much out of
them
that's all i'm gonna say so anyway uh as
i mentioned with the nightmare room this
is
easily easily four star read um it's
super fun
it's not not as creepy as the first one
but i just really liked all the
interdimensional like the demon [ __ ]
like the
the hungry ones are pretty creepy and
scary and
i really liked the imagery of them like
the kind of the bones and they kind of
like
formed themselves and [ __ ] like that so
it's like really really cool imagery
like that in there
i liked all the funny stuff i liked all
the build up
uh with jessie and getting all the motel
together and stuff like that for some
reason
i really like i really like stories
about like house like fixing up houses
and [ __ ] like i don't know what that is
maybe so i don't know what it says about
my psychology but uh but yeah so yeah so
i
kind of like enjoyed that kind of aspect
to it too and i really really liked the
tie-in with the first book
because as i said it goes like in an
alternate timeline kind of direction
like with some time traveling kind of
[ __ ] in there and i thought that was
really cool because i wasn't expecting
that
so yeah definitely definitely good read
and
i think you should pick it up but like i
said read them in order or at least like
read them
within a short time of each other so you
don't like forget all the details i
think that's how you're gonna get the
most enjoyment out of them
and that will do it for this tomes of
terror book review
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye